こんいちわ創星で cchan
can ちぇんじ精神先生爺し
トリミングスカイピースの仁丹ご存知でしょうか
ユーチューバーの中でも特に youtube ところですね肇社長としても有名なん
ですけどもうそんなことですね仁丹とちょっとだけ仲良くてですね
そんな人体が今ぼく地で出資しててアパ魂心身に遊びに来てるんですけども
そんなジンジャー今日は強風時意識に戻し0
を覚えます意志3期ですねたまたま人ランド超えたんですけども冷蔵庫を勝手に開いて
勝手に撮ってたんですよ
それが怖いそれが怖いけどもなんかそれよりしたいことがありまして
7にじんだんちょービビッててあーこれ絶対仁丹怖いだしスティな人だなと思って今日
はこんなものを準備しました
じゃあこちら
意外と美女でしたねー
まじかハイビームてっかーほんとはい皆ステッカーですね音が最近車の窓とかに変な
シール貼ってあることが多いと思うんですよタイミングを当てるとそのシールが
めちゃくちゃ見えるってやつなんですけどもそれの強い女でしたが出てくるば遊んで
ございます国しようと今から東京いるんですけども人体の車になって車で行くんです
けど今工場にありがとうの車はそしてその前にも
が車があるんで苗の車の後ろの窓にほど子を張って多いきまーすって言って持っている
車のライトをつけ配備した瞬間だ
潤担出身するかもしれませんじゃあ何かこういうある行きたいねんってなんですけども
不意打ちのこういうのがマジでちゃん強いんですよっていうわけで早速まずは黒に
仕掛けていこうと思いますよ線人体の中心角3封筒
[音楽]
uh
ああああああ
ええええええ
uh
[音楽]
cd 台の車がとありましたーこっちが乗る車ってこっちのここにこれが作って感じ
です
願っていますブーブ地みると結構怖いなぁあっだっつあるんだろうこれとこれ
この感じでってスパでこれ
まあまあ強い家と怖いけどストレートやなぁこれ
なんかといってこのも奏功しちゃダメだと思うんでこの走行しないですけどたぶんこう
いう奴なんでしょうね
何か着い花でも強いと思います
赤坂茶するそれはん
[音楽]
2つはさ
手抜きません
[拍手]
おめこ者的にいいねありがとうございます
抽選グルーヴすぎ大好きなんですよねお前ですか
[音楽]
ん
捏造んですか
東京にへ
膝東京ににうううううっ
[音楽]
ちゃん2
car
うううう
me
car
あっはぁ
[音楽]
ブービー一瞬ヌー haase
ティッシん苦しいシーズン senasena scc リース失禁してきて杖発揮
です